や！
はい、こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
えーと、
金、土、日と
イベントの関係で 三日間フルで稼働していました
ま、僕はですね、普段動画ばかり作っていて
皆さんに会いに行く機会がない中
まぁ すごい大変だったんですけども
皆さまと会えて僕はとても嬉しかったです
ほんとに皆さまに会えてよかったです
ありがとうございました！
が！
まぁ、あの僕基本的に毎日とはいってないんですけども
なるべく毎日動画出してて
その、三日間も 朝から夜まで全部、
イベントで動画も作る暇もなかった中
三日間、毎日動画を出すことができました！！
ありがとうございまぁぁす！！
ほんとにぃもぉぉぉ
頑張った～！
ほんとに頑張ったと思う
自分で言うのもなんかおかしいんですけど
いや、ほんとに頑張った結果
朝から夜までがイベントでほぼ時間がない中
どうやって動画を出したかといいますと
動画をたくさん撮っておいて
ぼく 編集に時間がかかるので
朝から夜まで全部イベント出た後に
夜のイベントが終わって
その夜から次の日の朝までの間に
なんとか編集をしておくという生活が
三日間続いて
割と、目の前がぼやけるぐらい
ちょっと 疲れております
まぁ、けど、かけがえのない時間を過ごせたと思います
ほんとに皆さんありがとうございます
いや、もう今たぶん気ぃ抜いたらもう寝ちゃうぐらいなんですよ
割と今ちょっと滅多にないぐらい限界レベルに疲れが来てて、
もう、ちょっと．．．
自分が誰が誰だか
分かんなくなってきてるぐらい疲れてるんですけども
スーースィーー（よだれ吸う音）
もうほぼ頭も回らない、体も動かない
この限界の状態で
今から友だちを笑わせてみようと思います
もう、細かい技術はいりません！
今まで生きてきた 本能的な知性と感性
生まれ持ったセンス
それだけを活かして
ちょっと今から友だちを
この限界な状態の時に笑わせてみようと思います
では行ってきます！！
滅多に見れませんよ
あと、疲れ てるから
あんまり
気にしないでね
深く考えないで．．．見てね
ッます！おぃッす！へっす！
よろしくおねがいしまっす
今回は、
笑ったら、負けです
いいですね？
（謎の奇声）
うあ゛ああああ゛ああああ゛ああ！！！！！！！！！！
（自分で笑う）
（謎の奇声）
友）ぶっｗｗ
友）それずるくない！？
はじめ）待って待って、ちょっと、
ほかの力で笑わせたい
友）そうだよ
は）今のはチートだね
友）うん
は）もう正々堂々と
は）いきますッ！
（謎の奇声）
おっほっほっほw
おっほっほっほっほw
おーーーーーーーーッ！！！
は）はぁ．．．はぁ．．．
（謎の奇声）
♬エンディングテーマ♬
は）今のやったっしょ！！！
よっしゃーーーー！！！！！！！！！